miles the decision to take jalen out
obviously has come under great scrutiny
locally and nationally
um the conversations amongst your
teammates i mean how do the guys feel
um
man if if i'm being honest if i'm being
honest no
nobody likes nobody and that's that's
all i can say
really but um i don't know what was the
who was the main person behind that
decision but um all that all i know is a
lot of people on the team
was confused
how about the first two sounds from
miles sanders
uh yeah ah yeah
it was like i really don't want to go
there but
screw it hey look credit to wip for
getting them on the air
you know one of the things that the
eagles really benefited from chris the
covet protocols that kept reporters out
of the locker room because i guarantee
you
if the reporters would have been
swarming over that locker room like they
would in a normal year
the quotes would have been epic and
endless from the players saying why the
hell do we do this
in fact i will go as far to say
that the eagles may not have done it if
they had known
that reporters were going to be in the
locker room immediately after the game
you know it's a it's an interesting
thought i mean because
it's one of those where even if players
don't answer
questions you're gonna see the raw
emotions on their face the rolling of
eyes the shrugging of shoulders
the disappointment you know in their
eyes all those type of things
to where you can't hide it you know i
don't know whether they would or
wouldn't have done it but you're right
it gives them a little bit of a free
pass the fact that nobody's gonna get in
the locker room for those reactions to
see that
and more importantly what happens
really in those locker rooms and moments
like that
at some point a veteran player who's
been around a little bit
and maybe has a little bit of a personal
relationship with one of the local beat
writers
he kind of tells them off to the side
hey we're pissed off
that i mean the team is pissed can you
believe they pulled that crap and all
that
and then that's where the beat writer
gets the inside track to go
the team the players are mad and pissed
off and of course that didn't happen
because of our
current circumstances and that's one of
the things that we have
missed for the entirety of the season
the opportunity for
reporters who have that access at a time
when people are more likely to be upset
they're less likely
to have a restrictor plate on the things
they may say
in that moment it's all very raw it's
all very fresh
and that's why we you know the stories
from past
years of hearing yelling and screaming
in the locker room and
and maybe there's a scuffle that that
happened that we don't know about and
and all those things get sanitized
through the video conferences with a
limited number of players after games so
would have been a very different reality
in that locker room on sunday night if
if reporters had been in there picking
up some of the reaction
like miles sanders even though he didn't
play he's still around the team
and the players who did play they're
going to be upset about what happened
clearly and obviously and chris this
isn't going away
no way for the eagles they're not going
to shake this and
the problem now is what do you do if
you're doug peterson do you start
talking individually to the players and
admit to them what you did
the words eventually going to get out
that you're admitting to what you did
and they can't admit to what they did
because i believe the minute that they
do that
that is when the nfl will descend on
them like they did on the patriots every
time they've been accused of cheating
like they did on the saints with
bountygate
the nfl as long as the eagles don't come
out and say it will look the other way
if they come out and say it or if
there's evidence emerging that they're
admitting to it
that's when the eagles have a problem i
i guess so i want to be like the
why what can the nfl do i i don't
understand that
you know i agree the game i i integrity
of the game
i committed an infraction against the
integrity of the game you have shaken
public confidence and trust in the
integrity of the game
and you throw the betting angle in i'm
surprised that hasn't been a bigger deal
congress has far bigger issues to deal
with right now but the betting angle
when you have people who are making
wagers based upon the assumption
that the team is going to try to win
remember the point you made yesterday
jim schwartz this is
a no hat t-shirt game right you i
thought you thought we all thought the
eagles were playing to win that game
it's the last game of the regular season
they're going to go for it it's a chance
to give jalen hurts
a game under the lights in in a
high-pressure setting
and let's see if you can beat washington
knocking out of the playoffs and we go
into the
off-season on a high note and and that's
why i picked them
and you picked them and we were wrong
yeah we had known what they were going
to do
we wouldn't have picked them well and to
your point somebody knew
i read your article yesterday on pro
football talk somebody knew
the eagles were favored by one point
when the line opened up last week
the week went on and all of a sudden
what was washington favored by the start
of the game six
six and a half it's a closing line so
somebody knew somebody in philadelphia
told somebody
and somebody made a lot of money last
week because of it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports